there's a lot of interesting stuff to
ask about language like you could look
at how would that work you go like at
gpt1 gpt2 gpt3 35
4 and try analyze the kind of language
it produces I mean that's almost trying
to look at assembly index of in
intelligent systems yeah I mean I think
um the thing about large language
models um and this is a whole hobby
horse I have at the moment um is that
obviously they're they're all about the
the the in the evidence of evolution in
the in the in the large language model
comes from all the people that produced
all the language and that's really
interesting and all the corrections in
the in the in the Mechanical Turk right
sure um and and so that's part of the
History part of the memory of the system
exactly so can you so so it would be
really interesting to basically use an
assembly based approach to to making
language in a hierarchy right I think is
my guess is that you could we might be a
build a new type of large language model
that uses assembly theory that it has
more understanding of the past and how
things were created well basically the
thing with llms is they like everything
everywhere all at once splat M and make
the user happy so there's not much
intelligence in the model the model is
how the human interacts with the model
but wouldn't it be great if we could
understand how to embed more
intelligence in them in the system what
do you mean by intelligence there like
you seem to uh associate intelligence
with history yeah well memory I think
selection produces
intelligence wa you're almost implying
that selection
is intelligence no yeah kind of I would
go that I would go out and limb and say
that but I think it's a little bit more
human beings have the ability to
abstract and they can break Beyond
selection and this is what why darwinian
selection um because a human being
doesn't have to basically do trial and
error like fact they can think about say
oh that's a bad idea won't do that and
then Technologies and so on so we
escaped darwinian Evolution and now
we're on to some other kind of evolution
I guess higher higher level level and
and we'll we'll assembly Theory will
measure that as well right because it's
all a lineage